back here in the US dangerous flash
flooding threatens more than four
million people this morning as an
unrelenting storm system hovers over
parts of the Northeast rising water
forced rescues and evacuations yesterday
in parts of Pennsylvania
states of emergency are in effect across
the region and in parts of the central
us the threat of heavy rainfall and
flash flooding extends through the week
Don Dahler is an Old Forge Pennsylvania
Don good morning good morning the
Lackawanna river here doesn't normally
have category 5 Rapids but it does today
if I were standing in this spot just a
few hours ago I'd have been underwater
and even though the waters have receded
slightly they're still at flood stage
still very dangerous with more rain on
the way
Pennsylvania Governor Tom wolf has
activated the state's Emergency Response
Coordination Center and has put the
National Guard on notice to be ready to
rescue anybody who gets into trouble
because of these floods powerful
floodwaters rushed through the streets
of Benton Pennsylvania while rescue
crews made the rounds in boats bringing
stranded people to safety
our dogs are trapped everybody's in
canoes
trying to save people outside
Philadelphia in Chester County rescue
crews used a boat and rope to save a 12
year old boy stranded in the middle of a
swollen stream flooding shut down
numerous roads including a major highway
the Schuylkill Expressway which was
closed in both directions at the King of
Prussia Mall near Philadelphia where the
rising waters also forced dozens of
stores to close come on
this is what nearly eight inches of rain
in just a few hours looks like in brick
New Jersey the flood waters filled the
inside of homes brick police declared a
state of emergency and more than 100
people were rescued in Pottsville the
cleanup started shortly after the water
receded crews repaired a road that
buckled under the flood waters on the
Lehigh River in Slatington about 70
miles north of Philadelphia
emergency crews scrambled to locate
nearly 150 missing rafters who were part
of a group that ran into trouble when
the weather worsened kayak instructor
jerry mac award helped rescue six young
women stuck in the middle of the river
one by one the girls were ferried across
a small pit of moving water to to safety
at riverbank and I am very happy to
report everyone who was on that raft
trip has been accounted for John good
news Don thanks